[Music]
so hey everyone my name is Bob Romano
and Emma 16 year old developer from
Thailand and this is for the love of
whip assembly hope you enjoyed it first
of all
javascript is a big ecosystem and this
is what makes us great as you can see
there is react
there's Redux and graph QL and a bunch
of other libraries and this makes our
ecosystems be together and we can create
any applications we want just like the
animals in deep in the forest now there
are some times when JavaScript alone
might not cut it for example when you
have performance problems you need more
performance you need more computation
power maybe you need to figure out a
face of someone and sometimes our suite
may not be enough or sometimes you just
need to get really low level and just
flip some bits and this is what our
friends come in with assembly and this
is like a tale of two worlds we have the
JavaScript wall with the world of
simplicity elegance and the world of web
assembly which is a world of performance
and once we combine these two words we
can open a porthole and make really
great apps now in webassembly it is a
binary format which you can use any
language you want but for now our
piecrust the reason I click grass is we
call first is really modern you can use
MapReduce you can use
many a lot a lot of libraries which can
make your life really easy and next Russ
is like my mom my mom loves to scowl at
me but she's has good intentions
so when you write really bad code Russ
will scream at you the compiler will not
let you compile until you make your code
good unless it is really fast Russ done
a lot of water shaking at compile time
so it can it can compile combine your
code and it makes everything really fast
and it can use a lot of LLVM
optimizations now I know a lot of you
might wonder how hard it is to use it
because it is from I know another world
another language but the good news is is
really easy first you have to import
your module which you can import like
another JavaScript module and the web
map loader will handle the rest for you
you can just await the module and then
you can call it like this from the
JavaScript function as usual now how do
you export your functions the cool new
is you can write your JavaScript
directly in rust so you can do consult
of log from rust you can do module on
exports from rust and anything anything
really you can modify the Dom you can
body you can modify the canvas and it
will call out to JavaScript just for you
and this is a great part so let's do
some demo shall we
[Music]
okay so here's my commit history and you
all can do this project at coopering /we
a trust and this is a starter kit so any
of you can go and download it right away
[Music]
okay so here's some knock-knock jokes
when I hit reply it will go call out to
rust and fish and fish some replies for
me here we go oh that wasn't what I
expected
okay so so the JavaScript code call-outs
rust and it gives us some replies let's
check the code and as you can see you
can just write react like you would as
usual but the good part is you can
simply import your web assembly
functions and use it in your readers
Redux reducer so here I just make Redux
akka listens for the actions and then it
will call out to webassembly
okay so really this is our I have to say
so thank you everyone for listening and
have a great time thank you
[Applause]